When I picked up the phone, it was my mom. And it had been about a month since we talked, which is not unusual and certainly my fault. Anyway, my mom said that she had been invited to speak with a group of women at the local Hadassah. My mom's a therapist in the Jewish suburbs outside Baltimore.
我接起电话，是我妈。我们已经有一个月没通电话了，这并不罕见，而且确实是我的错。总之，我妈说她受邀在当地的哈达萨妇女组织向一群女性发表演讲。我妈是巴尔的摩郊区犹太社区的一名心理治疗师。
And these Hadassah women had this group that met regularly. All of them were women in their late 40s through early 60s. And when the group first started meeting, they apparently discussed all sorts of things. It was wide ranging. But as time progressed, they realized that there was only one topic that they wanted to talk about and felt like they needed to talk about all the time, that they felt traumatized enough to have to talk about. And that was their relationships with their adult children.
这些哈达萨妇女有个定期聚会的小组。她们都是40多岁到60出头的女性。小组刚开始聚会时，她们似乎什么都聊，范围很广。但随着时间推移，她们意识到只有一个话题是她们想谈、觉得必须一直谈、且觉得受够了创伤必须谈论的，那就是她们与成年子女的关系。
And at some point, this became the only thing that the group talked about, its official reason for being. And they had invited my mother to lead a discussion about how to get along with your adult children. So my mom is a big preparer. When she gets invited to talk on various psychological topics, she looks up articles, calls experts, talks to people. And as part of her preparation, my mom decided to call her own three adult children to see what advice they would give to the group about communicating with your children, about having a good relationship with your adult children.
后来，这成了小组唯一讨论的事情，也是它存在的官方理由。她们邀请我母亲去引导一场关于“如何与成年子女相处”的讨论。我妈是个极其注重准备工作的人。每当受邀讨论各种心理学话题时，她都会查阅文章、咨询专家、与人交谈。作为准备工作的一部分，我妈决定给自己的三个成年子女打电话，看看他们会给这个小组提供什么建议，关于如何与子女沟通，如何与成年子女保持良好关系。
So my Mom had already talked to my older sister Randi out in California by the time she called me here in Chicago. And she explained to Randi, "It's a thing about communicating with your adult children and how to be close to your adult children." And she asked my sister what advice she would give to the group.
我妈在给我这个芝加哥的儿子打电话之前，已经跟我在加州的姐姐兰迪谈过了。她向兰迪解释说：“这是关于与成年子女沟通以及如何与他们保持亲密关系的话题。”她问我姐姐会给小组什么建议。
Randi's advice was direct and to the point. She said, "Tell them to get a different leader."
兰迪的建议非常直接、一针见血。她说：“告诉她们换个领导吧。”
Adult children, supposedly adult children, and their supposedly adult parents in this addition of This American Life from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass, back for another week documenting everyday stories in these United States.
成年子女，所谓的成年子女，以及他们所谓的成年父母，欢迎收听本期来自芝加哥WBEZ和公共广播国际公司的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯，又是一周的时间，继续记录发生在这片国土上的日常故事。
Today, Act One, Me and My Mom.
今天，第一幕，我和我的母亲。
Act Two, Sandra Tsing Loh and her father.
第二幕，桑德拉·青·罗和她的父亲。
Act Three, Sandra Tsing Loh, Her Father, and His Mail-Order Chinese Wives. Stay with us.
第三幕，桑德拉·青·罗、她的父亲，以及他邮购来的中国妻子。请继续收听。
So in this conversation with my mom, I was in the unusual position of being able to look like the good child in the family for a change. My older sister, for a change, looked like the bad kid. And I was able to say to my mom, you know, "Even if Randi thought that you weren't handling your relationships with us in the very best way, surely there was a way to express that that was a little less cruel."
在与我妈的那次谈话中，我处于一个不寻常的位置，难得能扮演家里那个好孩子。而我姐姐，也难得成了那个坏孩子。我得以对我妈说：“妈，即便兰迪觉得你处理我们关系的方式不是最好的，肯定也有种不那么残忍的表达方式吧。”
And my mom asked me, OK, so what advice would I have for this group? And I suggested that in the families of a lot of my friends and I think in my family, I thought that one cause of a lot of tension is the fact that as a family, we don't have a story that we agree on about the past. The kids, my sisters and I, we have one version of what happened when we were children. And that version tends to be kind of dark, actually. Not completely, but there's a lot of darkness in it. And our parents have a completely different story.
我妈问我，好吧，那我对这个小组有什么建议？我提出，在我很多朋友的家庭里，我想包括我们家在内，造成矛盾的一个原因在于，作为一个家庭，我们对过去并没有达成共识。孩子们，我和我姐姐们，对童年发生的事情有一个版本。而那个版本往往相当阴暗。并非完全如此，但其中有很多黑暗面。而我们的父母则有完全不同的故事。
And you know, I don't even think we need to come to a consensus. I don't think families need to agree about this stuff. I'm not even sure if they can agree. But I think there has to be some kind of mutual understanding that each side sees the past the way that they see it. So today's program will not be an attempt to find this common story, but it will be an attempt to define that gap as it exists in a few families. The holiday season is just ending and for so many people, the drama of the holidays is the drama of parents and grown children struggling to get along without disappointing each other or getting on each other's nerves.
你知道，我甚至认为我们不需要达成共识。我不认为家庭成员必须在这些事情上达成一致。我甚至不确定他们是否能达成一致。但我认为必须有一种相互理解，即双方都以各自的角度看待过去。所以今天的节目不会试图寻找这个共同的故事，而是会试图定义存在于少数家庭中的这种隔阂。假日季节刚刚结束，对许多人来说，节日的戏剧性就是父母和成年子女在努力相处时，为了不让对方失望或不触怒对方而上演的戏码。
So to begin our program right now, I'm pleased to welcome to our show, telephonically from Baltimore, my mom.
节目开始，我很高兴地欢迎我的母亲从巴尔的摩通过电话加入我们的节目。
Can I say something?
我能说点什么吗？
I was just going to say, feel free to amend or correct.
我正想说，随时欢迎修改或更正。
Yes. When I told your sister what you said, she said, "Oh, I was just kidding. I didn't mean to be mean."
好的。当我把你刚才说的话转告你姐姐时，她说：“噢，我只是开个玩笑，我没打算刻薄。”
Oh. Pfft.
哦。呵。
So I don't want her to be [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
所以我不想让她变得[无法听清]。
But you're a professional psychologist. Now, don't you think often-- don't you think that there was a note of hostility in what she said?
但你是一名专业心理学家。难道你不觉得，她的话里透着一丝敌意吗？
Oh, absolutely.
噢，当然。
OK. There, you see? Are you and I can agree. And frankly, she's not on the phone. So mom, the thing I wanted to ask you about is, OK, so you had this seminar with all these--
好吧。你看？我和你是可以达成共识的。说实话，她没在通话中。所以妈，我想问你的是，你当时举办了那个研讨会，有那么多——
It wasn't a seminar. It was a discussion group.
那不是研讨会。那是一个讨论小组。
Discussion. The discussion group, excuse me.
讨论小组。抱歉，讨论小组。
And I was the facilitator.
而且我是引导者。
And how many women was it?
有多少位女性参加？
Around 30-some.
三十多位吧。
Oh, so a lot. Now, if you had to characterize in a phrase people's relationships with their children, would you describe them as being very good, somewhat OK, generally kind of yucky? I mean, how would you describe it?
噢，那挺多的。如果让你用一个短语来形容人们与子女的关系，你会说非常好，还行，还是通常都很糟糕？你是怎么形容的？
I would say that there were a lot of people whose dreams haven't been realized, whose expectations haven't been met. And so there's a sense of disappointment, although there were some people there who were pleased with all aspects. And then, of course, the question was, "Well, why are you here?"
我会说，很多人梦想未实现，期望未满足。所以有一种失落感，尽管其中也有一些人对所有方面都感到满意。当然，问题随之而来：“那你们为什么会在这里？”
To gloat? Was that the answer? To gloat and show you pictures of grandchildren?
为了幸灾乐祸？是这个答案吗？为了幸灾乐祸，给你们看孙辈的照片？
A little bit.
有一点。
A little bit. Yeah, OK.
有一点。好吧，明白了。
More to connect with the other women, I suppose. But these are the criteria for satisfaction. Do you want to hear them?
我想更多是为了与其他女性建立联系。但这些是她们的满意度标准。你想听听吗？
Quickly.
快点说。
Whether their children were married, so that having single children was a disappointment.
孩子们是否结婚了，所以未婚子女是一种失望。
I'm just going to make a little checklist here. Taking [INAUDIBLE] my own--
我来列个清单。把我的[无法听清]也算上——
Whether their children lived close by of far away.
孩子们住在附近还是远方。
God, I'm shooting 0 for 2 so far. Keep going.
天哪，目前为止我两项全中（指不及格）。继续。
Whether their children appreciated them.
孩子们是否感激她们。
OK. I got 1 for 3.
好吧。我三项中了一项。
Whether they had grandchildren. Somebody announced that one of their children was pregnant with the first grandchild, and everybody went "Ooh," and they clapped. So that's the epitome. Whether their children were successful in their lives. How much they liked their child's spouse and got along with them.
是否有孙辈。有人宣布其中一个孩子怀上了第一个孙辈，大家都“噢”的一声，然后鼓掌。这就是典范。孩子们在生活中是否成功。她们有多喜欢子女的配偶，以及相处得如何。
You told me on the phone earlier something interesting about this.
你在电话里跟我说过关于这点的有趣之处。
Yes. I told you that there were several people there who did not like their child's choice of a partner at the time that they got married but had grown to love them very much and in some cases even liked them better than their own child.
是的。我告诉你，那里有几个人在孩子结婚时并不喜欢孩子选择的伴侣，但后来变得非常爱他们，在某些情况下甚至比对自己亲生子女还要喜欢。
See, now I wonder if that is because there is an inherent tension between children and their adult parents, that the child sometimes wants to be treated as the child and sometimes wants to be treated as an independent adult. And for the parent, it's pretty much a hellish guessing game. And then-- yeah?
你看，我怀疑这是不是因为父母和成年子女之间存在内在的张力，子女有时想被当作孩子对待，有时又想被当作独立的成年人。对于父母来说，这简直就是一场地狱般的猜谜游戏。然后——是的？
Yeah. A lot of people talked about walking on egg shells. And several people said, well, what's the right way to give advice? And of course the answer is, you don't give advice unless somebody asks you for it.
是的。很多人谈到如履薄冰。几个人问，给建议的正确方式是什么？当然答案是，除非对方要求，否则不要随便给建议。
Do you think that this relationship is harder, the relationship between adult children and their parents, is harder on the parents than on the children?
你认为这种关系，成年子女与父母之间的关系，对父母来说比对子女更难吗？
Yes. Because the parents have a dream of how they thought it was going to be, and it seldom matches the dream. One person said that her children are all single, all live far away, and she said she and her husband are very lonely. And what's happened, the good part, is that they've gotten much closer to each other because they realized that they were all that they have.
是的。因为父母对未来有种梦想，而它很少能与现实吻合。一个人说她所有的孩子都是单身，都住得很远，她说她和丈夫感到非常孤独。而发生的好事是，他们俩变得亲密多了，因为他们意识到对方是自己仅有的依靠。
Right. Well, Dr. Glass, I'm afraid that this would be about all the time we have for this particular segment of our radio show.
好吧。格拉斯医生，恐怕我们这期节目的这个环节时间到了。
Look, I'm glad for any time I can get with my children.
听着，我很高兴能有时间陪伴我的孩子们。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
All right. Touche.
好吧。算你赢。
My mom, Shirley Glass, a therapist in Baltimore. Coming up, a septuagenarian dad hitchhikes.
我的母亲，雪莉·格拉斯，巴尔的摩的心理治疗师。接下来，一位七旬老父亲去搭便车。
[MUSIC - "PARENTS ARE PEOPLE" BY MARLO THOMAS & FRIENDS]
[音乐 - 马洛·托马斯及朋友的《父母皆凡人》]
You know, I've just got to say. I'm just going to interrupt here. When you get into the genre of music about parents, you get into a real sorry lot of music, just a lot of bad music. I mean, we went on a little collection. We're talking about Cat Stevens' "Father and Son." Let's just-- I don't think I can take this song anymore. Let's just go for something else.
你知道，我得说，我要打断一下。当你进入关于父母的音乐流派时，你会发现大量糟糕的歌曲。我们收集了一些。我们谈论的是卡特·史蒂文斯的《父与子》。算了——我想我受不了这首歌了。我们换别的吧。
[MUSIC - "PISTOL PACKING PAPA" BY JIMMIE RODGERS]
[音乐 - 吉米·罗杰斯的《手枪老爸》]
Act Two, Sandra's Dad.
第二幕，桑德拉的父亲。
I insist that this be the last radio commentary about my father. OK, maybe I've never talked about him on the radio before. I just don't want this to become a habit.
我坚持这必须是关于我父亲的最后一次广播评论。好吧，也许我以前从未在广播里谈论过他。我只是不想让这成为习惯。
Sandra Tsing Loh is a writer, composer, pianist, and columnist for Buzz Magazine in Los Angeles. And we're actually going to bring you two stories from her about her father today, about how the adult children in her family deal with her father. This first story began as a column in Buzz Magazine. It also appears in Sandra's book, Depth Takes a Holiday. At one point, she and I adapted it for radio, and a shortened version of this story on NPR'S Morning Edition. Here's the whole story.
桑德拉·青·罗是一位作家、作曲家、钢琴家和洛杉矶《Buzz》杂志的专栏作家。今天我们要带给大家两个关于她父亲的故事，关于她家里的成年子女如何应付她的父亲。第一个故事最初是《Buzz》杂志的专栏文章。它也收录在桑德拉的书中《深度假期》。有一次，她和我将其改编成广播版，并在NPR的《早间新闻》节目中播出了缩减版。这是完整的故事。
Understand that for years, stories about my father, anecdotes that I thought were throwaways were the only thing anyone would ever remember about me. There I'd stand at parties, one hip jutted out, trying to tell amusing yet compelling stories about myself, at which point the dark-eyed man I was speaking with would lean forward, rest a hand lightly on my arm, and murmur, "You know, I've been wondering for years."
你要明白，多年来，关于我父亲的故事，那些我以为随口一提的轶事，成了人们记住我的唯一东西。我站在聚会上，一只手叉腰，试图讲述关于自己有趣又引人入胜的故事，这时那个与我交谈的黑眼睛男人会前倾，手轻轻搭在我的手臂上，低语道：“你知道，我好奇好几年了。”
"Yes," I'd breathe.
“什么？”我屏住呼吸。
A flame would leap into his eyes. "How is your dad? Does he still wear his underwear backwards and do the Chinese snake dance on Pacific Coast Highway?"
他眼中闪过一丝火花。“你爸爸怎么样了？他还把内裤反穿，在太平洋海岸公路跳中国蛇舞吗？”
I'd close my eyes in pain. "No. Of course not. Well, yes."
我痛苦地闭上眼睛。“不。当然不。好吧，是的。”
First, let's take a step backwards. Forget my dad. Immigrant parents in general tend towards eccentricity, don't they? They arrive from the old country, now they have VCRs and Cuisinarts, their children are growing up to be monsters, and worse, the local Ralph's stops carrying pig knuckles. For the record, my father does not wear his underwear backwards, only his sweaters. When the elbows wear through, you just turn them around and keep going. And yes, for the record, he did perform the Chinese snake dance for us kids, naked, armed only with a fluttering beach towel as he leaped and twirled, imparting his ancient Chinese folk song with a mournful howl. I know this may sound strange, but I've brought my father into the studio today to sing it. Papa?
首先，让我们后退一步。忘了我爸爸。移民父母通常都倾向于古怪，不是吗？他们从老家来到这里，现在有了录像机和食品加工机，他们的孩子长成了怪物，更糟的是，当地的拉尔夫超市不再卖猪蹄了。顺便声明，我父亲并不把内裤反穿，只是把毛衣反穿。当手肘磨穿了，你就把它翻过来继续穿。还有，顺便声明，他确实曾赤身裸体地为我们孩子跳过中国蛇舞，手里挥舞着一块海滩毛巾，一边跳跃一边旋转，发出哀伤的嚎叫声，唱着他的中国民间小调。我知道这听起来很奇怪，但我今天带父亲来录音室唱了一遍。爸爸？
OK. This so-called snake song, actually, I borrowed from old Chinese shepherds. So it sounds like this. [SINGING IN CHINESE]
好的。这个所谓的蛇舞歌，其实是我从中国老牧羊人那里学来的。听起来是这样的。[用中文演唱]
Dad's lived in Malibu for some 30 years now, threatening to cause property values to tumble along with him. Papa, I'm going to tell this story now the way I tell it. So I hope you're not embarrassed, OK?
老爸在马里布住了大概30年了，一直威胁着要让当地房价跟着他一起崩盘。爸爸，我现在要按我的方式讲这个故事了。希望你别尴尬，好吗？
OK. What choice do I have?
好的。我还有别的选择吗？
Once a neighbor called the police to complain. My father was hanging out his old underpants to dry, Shanghai-style, on clotheslines strung out in front of the garage. The underpants had holes in them. The complaint calls eventually stopped, but questions remain. Does my father, a retired aerospace engineer with science degrees from Stanford, Purdue, and Caltech, have to wear old underpants with holes in them? Is this a person who can afford, say, new underpants and a Maytag dryer, perhaps? "Why, yes," would have to be the answer. Right, papa?
有一次邻居报警投诉。我父亲像在上海一样，把他的旧内裤晾在车库前拉起的晾衣绳上。内裤上有洞。投诉电话最终停止了，但问题依然存在。我父亲，一位拥有斯坦福大学、普渡大学和加州理工学院科学学位的退休航空工程师，真的非要穿带洞的旧内裤吗？他是那种买不起新内裤和美泰烘干机的人吗？答案当然是“当然买得起”。对吧，爸爸？
Yeah.
是啊。
My father is one of those people who have untold stocks, bonds, mutual funds, IRAs, whatever, that they are continually shifting from one account to the next. For all his money, though, my father has always transported himself in and out of Malibu via hitchhiking. Yes, he owns his own car. He even bought me one, a Hyundai. He had to shelter income. But he doesn't like to drive. Say why.
我父亲属于那种拥有数不清的股票、债券、共同基金、个人退休账户等等，不断在账户间调拨资金的人。尽管有钱，但我父亲一直靠搭便车往返马里布。没错，他自己有车。他甚至给我买了一辆现代汽车。他为了避税。但他不喜欢开车。说为什么。
Oh, because the pollution. Also, the [INAUDIBLE], they only have 50 years. So we have to save this for the next, next generation.
噢，因为污染。而且[无法听清]，它们只有50年的寿命。所以我们必须为下一代、下一代的下一代保留这些资源。
But your particularly like hitchhiking.
但你特别喜欢搭便车。
HItchhiking, you can meet lots of people.
搭便车可以见到很多人。
Mm-hmm, especially in Los Angeles.
嗯，特别是在洛杉矶。
Now, beloved listeners, this is my commentary, so I'm going to try and give you my point of view, what I see. Usually I'm driving through Santa Monica and I'll come by, let's say, the corner of Wilshire and 4th. And there my father will be standing, clutching his lucky grocery bag of scientific papers trying to flag down a ride. I'll never not pick him up. That would be a little too how-sharp-the-sepant's-tooth. But I have been tempted to just put my foot on the gas pedal and race towards the Pacific happy and free like somebody who's 75-year-old dad is not still copping rides from the public.
亲爱的听众们，这是我的评论，所以我得从我的视角给你们讲讲。通常我开车经过圣莫尼卡，比如威尔希尔大道和第四街路口。我父亲就会站在那儿，紧紧抓着他那个装满科学论文的幸运购物袋，试图招手搭车。我永远不会不载他。那样太“不知恩图报”了。但我确实很想直接一脚油门，快乐自由地冲向太平洋，就像那些75岁老爸不靠搭便车过日子的正常人一样。
OK. This is your section. OK, let's talk about the day you got the really good ride. And where were you standing?
好的。这一段该你了。我们聊聊你那天搭到的那趟好车。你当时站在哪儿？
Well, I always get good rides. But that was an especially good ride. I had just come from the dentist's office in the late afternoon on Wilshire Boulevard near Western. And the first car stopped. A very gracious lady looked like Loretta Young, she drove up--
我总是能搭到好车。但那次特别好。那天傍晚，我刚从威尔希尔大道靠近西区的一家牙科诊所出来。第一辆车就停下了。一位非常优雅的女士，长得像洛蕾塔·杨，她开过来——
Looked like who?
长得像谁？
Loretta Young. You don't know, because very old movie star, very gracious lady. Loretta Young.
洛蕾塔·杨。你不知道，那是位非常老的电影明星，非常优雅的女士。洛蕾塔·杨。
Oh, like a Chinese movie star?
哦，像中国电影明星吗？
No, it's American. Loretta.
不，是美国的。洛蕾塔。
Oh, Loretta Young.
哦，洛蕾塔·杨。
Loretta Young, I'm sorry.
洛丽塔·扬，抱歉。
I thought you were saying Lori-Tai Young. OK, Loretta Young.
我以为你说的是洛丽·泰·扬。好的，洛丽塔·扬。
Loretta Young.
洛丽塔·扬。
OK, OK.
好的，好的。
And she was very gracious, without no hesitation let me in the backseat of her four-door Mercedes sedan. Because in the front seat, the passenger seat was occupied by a young man. So then we talk of different things. I say, what kind of business you people in? They say movie business. Ah, I says, that's exciting.
她非常亲切，毫无犹豫地让我坐进了她那辆四门奔驰轿车的后座。因为前排的乘客座椅上坐着一位年轻男士。于是我们聊了一些别的话题。我问：“你们是做什么生意的？”他们说：“电影生意。”我说：“啊，那真令人兴奋。”
You said she had known a lot about Chinese opera and film?
你说她对中国戏曲和电影了解很多？
Oh, yes. We discussed many Chinese movies. So she knows quite a lot. And then somehow we talk about the Clintons. And the lady said, "Yeah, I like both Hillary and Bill. We were in The White House recently."
哦，是的。我们讨论了很多中国电影。她了解得相当多。然后不知怎么的，我们谈到了克林顿一家。那位女士说：“是啊，我挺喜欢希拉里和比尔的。我们最近刚去过白宫。”
Then I say, "What's your name?"
然后我说：“你叫什么名字？”
She say, "Anjelica Huston."
她说：“安杰丽卡·休斯顿。”
I say, "Wow. I don't go movies so I don't know much movie stars. But I do know Huston family. Because your father, John Huston passed, a few years, away. I haven't kept track on your family's story."
我说：“哇。我不怎么看电影，所以对电影明星了解不多。但我知道休斯顿家族。因为你父亲约翰·休斯顿几年前去世了。我一直没关注你们家族的故事。”
Note that that's an important point for my father. Because unlike Ms. Huston, I didn't go into my father's business, science, and it's been a little disappointing. But she gave you a letter, right?
要注意，这一点对我父亲来说很重要。因为不像休斯顿小姐，我没有继承父业——科学，这让他有点失望。但她给了你一封信，对吧？
I asked her, "Can you give me your autograph?" So finally, she turned an envelope back. It says like this-- "To Mr. Loh. It was a pleasure to have you in my car." Then a heart with two wings. Then "Love, Anjelica Huston." Then down there "XXXX." Being Chinese, I don't know what the "XXX" means. Then later, I asked my friend. They said, "That's kissing, kissing, kissing."
我问她：“你能给我签个名吗？”最后，她把一个信封翻过来。上面写着——“致罗先生。很高兴能在我的车里载到你。”然后画了一颗心，两边有两个翅膀。接着写着“爱你的，安杰丽卡·休斯顿。”再下面写着“XXXX”。作为中国人，我不知道“XXX”是什么意思。后来我问朋友，他们说：“那是亲亲，亲亲，亲亲。”
OK. So there's the story. Here's the way I remember my dad first telling me and ending this. I remember you said that while Anjelica Huston was a good ride, she wasn't a dream ride. Because she had this friend to drop off in Beverly Hills, which took you a little out of your way. And at that point, it would've been quicker for you to take the crosstown bus because you had to transfer. But by then, I remember you lowered your voice, you're an expert in such delicate matters of decorum, and you said that you thought at that point, getting out might be a little rude. Papa, why don't you just take us out with a song?
好的。故事就是这样。这是我记忆中父亲第一次讲这个故事并以此结尾的方式。我记得你说过，虽然安杰丽卡·休斯顿是一段不错的旅程，但并不是梦幻般的旅程。因为她还得送那位朋友去比弗利山庄，这让你稍微绕了点路。那时候，如果你换乘公交车可能会更快，因为你还得转车。但我记得那时候你压低了声音——你可是处理这种礼仪琐事的专家——你说你觉得在那会儿下车可能不太礼貌。爸爸，你为什么不给我们唱首歌来结尾呢？
Another song?
还要唱一首吗？
Yeah.
是的。
This song, usually I sing it with my wife. Since today Sandra didn't invite my wife, I have to let her stay in the kitchen at home. This song describes some young woman longing for her lover. Sounds like this. [SINGING IN CHINESE]
这首歌我平时是和我妻子合唱的。既然今天桑德拉没请我妻子，我只好让她留在家里厨房了。这首歌描述的是一位年轻女子对情人的思念。听起来是这样的。[用中文演唱]
Sandra Tsing Loh and her father in Los Angeles. This music, by the way, is also by Sandra. She composes and performs. This is from her album, Piano Vision. They play this music sometimes on Morning Edition. After the little news breaks, sometimes you can hear these little piano riffs from this record. Anyway, more parents and adult children coming up.
桑德拉·青·罗和她的父亲在洛杉矶。顺便说一下，这段音乐也是桑德拉创作的。她负责作曲和演奏。这出自她的专辑《钢琴视觉》(Piano Vision)。他们在《晨间版》(Morning Edition)节目中有时会播放这段音乐。新闻简报结束后，有时你能听到唱片里传出的钢琴旋律。总之，接下来还有更多关于父母与成年子女的话题。
[MUSIC - "ALL APOLOGIES" BY SINEAD O'CONNOR]
[音乐 - 希妮德·奥康娜的《所有歉意》(All Apologies)]
[MUSIC - "BE A FATHER TO YOUR CHILD" BY ED O.G. & DA BULLDOGS]
[音乐 - Ed O.G. & Da Bulldogs的《做你孩子的父亲》(Be a Father to Your Child)]
Coming up, Sandra Tsing Loh, her father, and his new mail-order Chinese brides. That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，桑德拉·青·罗、她的父亲，以及他新找的邮购中国新娘。一分钟后，国际公共广播电台的节目继续播出。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week, of course, on our program, we invite a variety of writers and performers to tackle some theme that we choose. Our theme today is families in which the parents and the children see the story of their family in radically different ways. And rather than have a whole big bunch of different kinds of performers, actually we're only having one performer on the show today, Sandra Loh.
这里是《美国生活》(This American Life)。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周，在我们的节目中，我们都会邀请各种作家和表演者来探讨我们选定的主题。今天的主题是：父母与子女对家庭故事的看法截然不同的家庭。与其找一大堆不同类型的表演者，今天我们节目只邀请了一位表演者，桑德拉·罗。
And we have arrived at Act Three of our program. This is a story called "My Father's Chinese Wives." Sandra has performed this a lot around Los Angeles and, most recently, in New York City in a show called Aliens in America.
现在进入节目的第三幕。这个故事名为《我父亲的中国妻子们》。桑德拉已经在洛杉矶演出过多次，最近一次是在纽约市的《美国外星人》(Aliens in America)演出中。
My father has decided at age 70 to take a Chinese wife. He has written his family in Shanghai seeking their help in locating likely candidates. He has good confidence in this project. He's hoping to be married in six months.
我父亲决定在70岁时娶一位中国妻子。他已经写信给在上海的家人，请求他们帮忙寻找合适的人选。他对这个计划信心十足。他希望在六个月内结婚。
Let's unpeel this news one layer at a time. Question, is my father even what one would consider marriageable at this point? At age 70, my father, a retired Chinese aerospace engineer, is starting to look more and more like somebody's gardener. His feet shuffle along the patio in their broken sandals. He stoops to pull out one or two stray weeds, coughing phlegmatically. Later, he sits in a rattan chair and eats leathery green vegetables in brown sauce, his old eyes slitted wearily.
让我们一层层剖析这个消息。问题是，我父亲在这把年纪还算是个适婚对象吗？70岁的父亲，一位退休的中国航空工程师，看起来越来越像某个人的园丁。他的双脚穿着破凉鞋在露台上挪动。他弯腰拔掉一两根杂草，发出带痰的咳嗽声。之后，他坐在藤椅上，吃着沾着褐色酱汁的干硬绿色蔬菜，那双老眼里带着疲惫的细缝。
At times, he almost seems to be overacting this lizardy old part. He milks it. "I am old now," he'll say with a certain studied poignance. "I am just your crazy old Chinese father." If he's that old, why does he still do the same vigorous daily exercise regime he's done for the past 10 years? 45 minutes of pull-ups, something that looks like The Twist and much unfocused bellowing. This always performed on the most public beach as possible in his favorite Speedo, one he found in a dumpster.
有时，他似乎在过度扮演这个“怪异老头”的角色。他甚至刻意卖弄。他会带着一种苦心经营的酸楚感说：“我现在老了。我只是你那个疯狂的中国老爸。”如果他真的那么老，为什么他还要坚持过去10年来一直做的剧烈日常锻炼计划呢？45分钟的引体向上，做一些看起来像“扭扭舞”的动作，还有许多没缘由的吼叫。这些动作总是在尽可能公共的海滩上进行，穿着他在垃圾箱里捡来的最爱的那条泳裤。
No, crazy old Chinese father is, in truth, a code word, a rationalization for the fact that my father has always had a hard time spending money. Why buy a leather briefcase to take to work when an empty Frosted Flakes cereal box will do just as well? Papers slip down neatly inside, pens can be clipped conveniently on either end. Why buy Bounty paper towels when at work he can just walk down the hall to the washroom, open the dispenser, and list out a stack. They're free. He can bring home as many as we want. If you've worn the same sweater for so many years that the elbows wear out, turn it around. Get another decade out of it. Wear it backwards. Which is why, to this day, my father wears only crew-neck, not V-neck sweaters.
不，“疯狂的中国老爸”实际上是一个代号，是他一直舍不得花钱的合理化借口。为什么上班要买皮质公文包，明明空的麦片包装盒也能用？文件整齐地滑进去，笔可以顺手夹在两边，多方便。为什么买邦迪纸巾，在公司明明可以走到走廊尽头的洗手间，打开纸巾盒，抽出一叠来。它们是免费的。他可以随心所欲带多少回家。如果你穿了同一件毛衣很多年，手肘都磨破了，那就翻过来穿。再穿它十年。反过来穿。这就是为什么直到今天，我父亲只穿圆领毛衣，而不穿V领的。
"Terrific," is my older sister Kaitlin's response when I phone her with the news. Bear in mind that Kaitlin has not seen my father since the mid-80s, preferring to nurture bad memories of him independently via a therapist. She allows herself a laugh, laying aside her customary dull hostility for a moment of more jocular hostility. "So who does he think would want to marry him?"
“太棒了，”当我打电话把消息告诉姐姐凯特琳时，她的回应是这样的。请记住，凯特琳自80年代中期以来就没见过我父亲，她宁愿通过心理医生独立地呵护对他那些糟糕的记忆。她让自己笑了一声，暂时放下了习惯性的沉闷敌意，转而带上了一种更戏谑的敌意。“那么，他觉得谁会想嫁给他？”
"Someone Chinese," I answer.
“中国人，”我回答。
"Oh, good," she exclaims. "That narrows down the field to, what, half a billion? No. As usual, he's doing this to punish us. Think about it," she continues, with her usual chilling logic, "he marries a German woman the first time around. It's a disaster-- you and I symbolize that-- because he's passive-aggressive and he's cheap. But no. To him, it's that rebellious, Aryan strain that's the problem. You take an Asian immigrant just off the boat, for example. Here's a woman fleeing a life of oppression under a Communist government and no public sanitation and working in a bicycle factory for $0.10 an hour and repeated floggings every hour on the hour, every day of every week of every month of every year. After that, living with our father might seem like just another bizarre incident of some kind."
“噢，好极了，”她惊呼道。“那把范围缩小到了，什么，五亿人？不。和往常一样，他做这一切是为了惩罚我们。想想看，”她继续说道，带着她一贯令人胆寒的逻辑，“他第一次娶了个德国女人。结果是一场灾难——你和我就是那场灾难的象征——因为他是个被动攻击型人格，而且吝啬。但不是，对他来说，问题在于那种叛逆的雅利安血统。比如，你找一个刚下船的亚洲移民。这是一个逃离共产党政府压迫、缺乏公共卫生设施、在自行车厂以每小时10美分薪水工作、每天每时每刻都要遭受鞭笞的女人。在那之后，和我们的父亲住在一起可能看起来就像某种离奇的经历。”
"It could happen." Kaitlin scores some compelling points, but nonetheless, I'm bothered for a different reason. Because in describing the potential new wife, he has used only that one adjective, "Chinese." He has not said, "I'm looking for a smart wife," or even "a fat wife." He has picked "Chinese." That word is meant to stand for so much. Asian. Asian women. Young Asian ladies.
“这倒有可能。”凯特琳指出了几个令人信服的论点，但我仍然因为另一个原因感到困扰。因为在描述这位潜在的新妻子时，他只用了那个形容词——“中国”。他没有说“我想找个聪明的妻子”，甚至没有说“找个胖妻子”。他挑了“中国”。那个词被赋予了太多的含义。亚洲。亚洲女性。年轻的亚洲女士。
It is a month later and, as if in a dream, I sit at the worn, Formica family dining room table with my father, photos and letters spread out before us. Since my father has written to Shanghai, the mail has come pouring in. I have to face the fact that my father is, well, hot. "You see?" he says. "Seven women have written. Ha." He beams, his gold molar glinting. He drinks steaming green tea from a chipped laboratory beaker which he handles with a Beauty and the Beast potholder.
一个月后，我就像在做梦一样，和父亲坐在那张磨损的福米卡材质家庭餐桌旁，照片和信件铺在面前。自从父亲写信给上海后，邮件就源源不断地涌来。我不得不面对一个事实：我父亲，好吧，是个抢手货。“你瞧？”他说，“有七个女人写信来了。哈。”他眉开眼笑，金色的臼齿闪闪发光。他用一个缺了口的实验室烧杯喝着冒热气的绿茶，手里还拿着一个“美女与野兽”主题的隔热垫。
Remarkably, my father doesn't make the least effort to mask his delight, no matter how inappropriate. He is old now. He can do whatever the hell he wants, is how I now understand it. With a sigh, I turn to the photos. And in spite of myself, I am wowed. Tsao Pa, Ling Ling, Siu Pai. 28, administrative assistant. 47, owner of a seamstress business. 39, freelance beautician. The words jump off the pages, both in English and Chinese translations. These women are dynamos, achievers, with curly black hair, in turtlenecks, jauntily riding bicycles, seated squarely on cannons before military museums, standing proudly with three, full-grown daughters. One thing unites them. They're all ready to leap off the mainland at the drop of a hat.
令人惊讶的是，无论多么不合时宜，父亲一点也不掩饰他的喜悦。他现在老了。我终于明白，他想干什么就干什么。叹了口气，我翻看起照片。尽管我不愿意承认，但我还是惊呆了。曹帕、玲玲、秀派。28岁，行政助理。47岁，服装店老板。39岁，自由职业美容师。这些文字从页面上跳出来，中英文对照。这些女人都是女强人、成功人士，留着黑色卷发，穿着高领毛衣，兴致勃勃地骑着自行车，端坐在军事博物馆前的火炮上，自豪地站着，身边是三个成年的女儿。有一点把她们联系在了一起：她们都准备好只要一有机会就逃离中国大陆。
And don't think their careers and hobbies are going to keep them from being terrific wives. Quite the opposite. Several already have excellent experience, including one who's been married twice already. The seamstress has sent him shorts and several pairs of socks. There's much talk of seven-course meals and ironing and terrific expertise in gardening. Super achievement is a major theme that applies to all.
别以为她们的职业和爱好会妨碍她们成为出色的妻子。恰恰相反。有几位已经非常有经验了，包括一位已经结过两次婚的。那位裁缝还给他寄了短裤和好几双袜子。信中有很多关于做七道菜的宴席、熨衣服以及园艺方面精湛技术的描述。超级成就感是适用于所有人的主题。
But the biggest star of all, of course, is my father. He clears his throat and gleefully reads from a letter by one Liu Sun. It reads, "Dr. Loh, your family has told me of your excellent scientific genius and your many awards. I respect academic scholarship very highly and would be honored to meet you on your next visit."
但当然，最耀眼的明星还是我父亲。他清了清嗓子，兴高采烈地读起一位叫刘孙的女人写的信。信上写道：“罗博士，您的家人告诉我您有杰出的科学天才和许多奖项。我非常尊重学术研究，如果能在您下次访问时见到您，我将不胜荣幸。”
"You see," my father chuckles. They have a lot of respect for me in China. When I go there, they treat me like President Bush. Free drinks, free meals. I do not pay for anything."
“你瞧，”父亲轻声笑道。“在中国，他们非常尊重我。我去那里的时候，他们把我当布什总统一样对待。免费饮品，免费餐食。我什么都不用花钱。”
"He had his chance. He got married once for 25 years. He was a terrible husband and a worse father." Kaitlin is weighing in. All jokes are off. Her fury blazes away, further aggravated by the fact that she is going through a divorce and hates her $50,000-a-year job. Her monthly Nordstrom bills are astronomical. MCI is positively crackling.
“他以前有机会。他结过一次婚，过了25年。他是个糟糕的丈夫，更是一个糟糕的父亲。”凯特琳介入了。所有的玩笑都结束了。她的愤怒如火焰般燃烧，再加上她正在经历离婚，而且讨厌她那份年薪五万美元的工作，这让她的怒火更甚。她每月在诺德斯特龙百货公司的账单高得惊人。电话里的火药味十分浓重。
"He's a single man," I say. "Mom's been gone for 12 years now."
“他是个单身男人，”我说。“妈妈已经去世12年了。”
"And now he gets a second try? Just like that?" Kaitlin exclaims. "Clean slate? Start right over? Buy a wife? It makes me sick. He is totally unqualified to sustain a marriage. A family structure of any kind collapses around him. Do you even remember one happy Christmas?"
“现在他有了第二次机会？就这么简单？”凯特琳惊呼道。“白纸一张？重新开始？买个老婆？真让我恶心。他根本没资格维持婚姻。任何形式的家庭结构在他身边都会分崩离析。你还记得过一次快乐的圣诞节吗？”
Twinkling lights and tinsel suddenly swirl before me. And looking deeper, through green foliage, I see my mother looking beautiful and crisp in lipstick and pearls, her wavy, auburn hair done. Except for the fact that she is hysterical. And my father, his face a mask of disgust so extreme it is almost [UNINTELLIGIBLE], is holding his overpriced new V-neck tennis sweater from Saks out in front of him like it was a dead animal. "I try to block it out," is what I say.
闪烁的灯光和金属丝突然在我眼前晃动。深入回想，穿过绿色的树叶，我看到母亲涂着口红，戴着珍珠项链，波浪般的红褐色头发梳理得整整齐齐，看起来既漂亮又精神。除了她正陷入歇斯底里状态这一事实外。而我的父亲，脸上带着一种极其厌恶的表情，近乎[听不清]，他拿着那件从萨克斯百货买来的昂贵的新V领网球毛衣，像拿着一只死动物一样举在面前。“我试着不去想它，”我说道。
"Well, I was six years older than you so I can't." Kaitlin's pain is raw. "Why does he deserve to be happy now? He made Mama miserable all her lifetime. He was so cheap. I think she was almost glad to go as soon as she did. A $70 dress, leaving the heater on overnight, too much spent on a nice, steak dinner. He could never let anything go. He could never just let it go. He just could not-- let-- things-- go."
“好吧，我比你大六岁，所以我忘不掉。”凯特琳的痛苦是赤裸裸的。“为什么他现在理应感到幸福？他让妈妈痛苦了一辈子。他太吝啬了。我觉得她一走可能还感到庆幸。一条70美元的裙子，整晚开着加热器，在昂贵的牛排晚餐上花太多钱。他永远不能让任何事情过去。他永远不能让事情顺其自然。他就是不能——让——事情——过去。”
Meanwhile, on its own gentle time clock, unsullied by the raging doubts of his two daughters, my father's project bursts into flower. And 47-year-old Liu, the writer of the magic letter, is the lucky winner. Within three months, she's flown to Los Angeles. She and my father are married a week later. I do not get to meet her right away, but my father fills me in on the stats.
与此同时，在他自己的温柔时钟里，不受两个女儿狂暴怀疑的影响，父亲的计划开花结果了。47岁的刘女士，那封神奇信件的作者，成了幸运儿。不到三个月，她就飞到了洛杉矶。她和父亲在一周后结婚了。我没能立刻见到她，但父亲向我透露了她的背景。
And I have to confess, I'm surprised at how urban she is, how modern. Liu is a divorcee with, well, ambitions in the entertainment business. Although she speaks no English, she seems to be an expert on American culture. The fact that Los Angeles is near Hollywood has not escaped her. This is made clear to me one Sunday evening three weeks later via telephone.
我必须承认，她那种都市感和现代感让我很惊讶。刘女士是一位离异女性，有着，嗯，进入娱乐业的雄心。虽然她不会说英语，但她似乎是美国文化的专家。洛杉矶靠近好莱坞这一事实并没有逃过她的眼睛。这一点在三周后的一个周日晚上通过电话传达给了我。
"I know you have friends in the entertainment business," my father declares. He has never fully grasped the fact that I am a typist and that Swanson's Films clients include such Oscar contenders as Kraft Foods and Motorola. "Aside from having knitted me a sweater and playing the piano," my father continues, "you should know that Liu is an excellent singer." Turning away from the phone, he and his new wife exchange a series of staccato reports in Mandarin which mean nothing to me.
“我知道你在娱乐业有朋友，”父亲宣称。他从来没完全理解我是个打字员，而斯旺森电影公司的客户包括卡夫食品和摩托罗拉这种奥斯卡级别的竞争者。“除了给我织了毛衣和弹钢琴之外，”父亲继续说，“你应该知道，刘女士是一位出色的歌手。”他转过身去，和他的新婚妻子用普通话进行了一连串简短的交谈，我一句也听不懂。
"I'm sure Liu is quite accomplished," I reply. "It's just that--"
“我相信刘女士很有才华，”我回答。“只是……”
"Oh, she is terrific," my father exclaims, shocked that I could be calling Liu's musical talent into question. "You want to hear her sing? Here, here. I will put her on the phone right now." Creeping into my father's voice is a tremulous tone that's sickeningly familiar. How many times had I heard it during my childhood as I was pushed towards the piano kicking and screaming? How many times?
“噢，她太棒了，”父亲惊呼道，显然对我会质疑刘女士的音乐天赋感到震惊。“你想听她唱吗？来，来。我现在就把电话给她。”父亲的声音里透出一种令人作呕的熟悉的颤抖。在童年时期，当我就像被踢打着、尖叫着被推向钢琴时，这种声音我听过多少次？多少次？
But that was 20 years ago. I gulped terror back down. I live in my own apartment now, full of director's chairs, potted ficuses, and Matisse posters. I will be fine. My father has moved on to a totally new [? pushy ?] who picks up the phone, clears his throat, then bursts out triumphantly [SINGING IN CHINESE]
但那是20年前的事了。我把恐惧咽了回去。我现在住在自己的公寓里，里面摆满了导演椅、盆栽榕树和马蒂斯的海报。我会没事的。父亲已经转向了一个完全陌生的[？爱管闲事的人]，她接起电话，清了清嗓子，然后得意洋洋地唱了起来。[用中文演唱]
"I have left you, Dr. Loh, and taken the Toyota. So there." Five weeks later, Liu just packs her suitcase, makes some sandwiches and takes off in the family Toyota. She leaves her note on the same Formica family dining room table at which she'd first won my father's heart. My father is in shock. Then again, he's philosophical.
“我离开你了，罗博士，而且我开走了丰田车。就这样。”五周后，刘女士收拾好行李，做了些三明治，开着家里的丰田车跑了。她在那张福米卡家庭餐桌上留下了一张字条，那正是她当初俘获我父亲芳心的地方。父亲大受打击。不过，他又变得很达观。
"That Liu, she was bad, that one. [SPITS] She says I do not like to give her gifts. She says I do not like to go out at night, and it is true. I do not. But I say go. See your friends in Chinatown. It is OK with me. I like it better when she leaves the house sometimes. It is more quiet. But Liu does not want to take the bus. She wants to drive the car. But you know me. I am your crazy old Chinese father. I do not like to pay for her auto insurance." And then he actually says, "As with many Asians, Liu is a very bad driver."
“那个刘，她很坏。[吐唾沫] 她说我不喜欢给她礼物。她说我不喜欢晚上出门，这是真的。我确实不喜欢。但我说你去吧。去看看你在唐人街的朋友。我没意见。她有时离开家我倒觉得更好。更安静。但刘不想坐公交车。她想开我的车。但你了解我。我是你那个疯狂的中国老爸。我不想付她的汽车保险费。”然后他竟然说：“像许多亚洲人一样，刘开车非常糟糕。”
"Ha," is Kaitlin's only comment. "Isn't it interesting how he seems to repel even his own kind?"
“哈，”这是凯特琳唯一的评论。“他居然连自己同族的人都能排斥，这难道不有趣吗？”
Summer turns to fall in Southern California, causing the palm trees to sway a bit. The divorce is soon final, Liu's settlement including $10,000, the microwave, and the Toyota. Never one to dwell, my father has picked out a new bride, Zhu Ping, 37, homemaker from the Guangzhou province. I groan.
夏天转入秋天，南加州的棕榈树随风摇曳。离婚很快生效了，刘女士的赔偿包括一万美元、微波炉和那辆丰田车。父亲从来不是那种会沉溺于过去的人，他已经挑中了一位新娘，朱萍，37岁，来自广东省的家庭主妇。我呻吟了一声。
"But no, Zhu Ping is very good," my father insists. He has had several phone conversations with her. "And she comes very highly recommended, not, I have to say, like Liu. She was bad, that one. [SPITS] Zhu Ping is very sensible and hardworking. She has had a tough life. Boy. She worked in a coal mine in Manchuria until she was 25 years old. The winters there were very, very bitter. She had to make her own shoes and clothing. Then she worked on a farming collective where she raised cattle and grew many different kinds of crops by herself."
“但是不，朱萍非常好，”父亲坚称。他和她通过好几次电话。“而且她评价很高，我得说，不像刘。那个很坏。[吐唾沫] 朱萍非常通情达理，勤劳能干。她过得很辛苦。孩子。她一直在满洲的煤矿工作到25岁。那里的冬天非常非常寒冷。她得自己做鞋子和衣服。后来她在一家农场工作，自己养牛，种各种作物。”
"I'm sure she's going to fit in really well in Los Angeles," I say.
“我相信她会很好地适应洛杉矶的生活，”我说。
Zhu Ping, indeed, is a difference sort. The news, to my astonishment, comes from Kaitlin. "I received--" Her voice trails off, the very words seeming to elude her. "A birthday card from Papa and Zhu Ping." My sister continues in a kind of trance of matter-of-factness, as if describing some curious archaeological artifact. "On the cover, there is a clown holding balloons. It's from Hallmark. Inside, in gold lettering, cursive, it reads, 'Happy birthday, love Zhu Ping and your Daddy.'"
朱萍确实与众不同。让我吃惊的是，消息是从凯特琳那里传来的。“我收到了——”她的声音变得微弱，似乎连词句都从脑海中溜走了。“一张生日贺卡，是爸爸和朱萍寄来的。”姐姐以一种恍惚的冷淡口吻继续说道，仿佛在描述某种奇特的考古文物。“封面是一只拿着气球的小丑。是霍尔马克(Hallmark)出的。里面，用金色的连体字写着，‘生日快乐，爱你的朱萍和爸爸’。”
"Your what?"
“你的什么？”
"I think Zhu Ping put him up to this. The envelope is not addressed in his handwriting. Nonetheless," Kaitlin thinks it over, concurs with herself, "yes, yes. I believe this is the first birthday card I've ever received from him in my life. The first. It's totally bizarre."
“我觉得是朱萍让他这么做的。信封上的地址不是他的笔迹。不过，”凯特琳考虑了一下，对自己表示赞同，“是的，是的。我相信这是我一生中从他那里收到的第一张生日贺卡。第一张。真是太离奇了。”
A week later, Kaitlin receives birthday gifts in the mail. A sweater, hand-knit by Zhu Ping, a box of moon cakes, a bunch of orchids. She is flipping out. "Oh no," she worries, "now I really have to call and thank her. I mean, the poor woman probably has no friends in America. Who knows what he's having her do? We may be her only link to society."
一周后，凯特琳收到了邮寄来的生日礼物。一件朱萍亲手织的毛衣，一盒月饼，一束兰花。她快疯了。“噢不，”她担忧地说，“现在我真的必须打电话去谢谢她了。我是说，这个可怜的女人在美国可能一个朋友都没有。谁知道他在让她做什么？我们可能是她与社会唯一的联系了。”
Kaitlin finally does call, managing to catch Zhu Ping when my father is out on the beach doing his exercises. Although Zhu Ping's English is very broken, she somehow convinces Kaitlin to fly down for a visit. It will be Kaitlin's first trip home since our mother's passing and my first meeting of either of my father's two Chinese wives.
凯特琳终于打了电话，趁父亲出去海滩锻炼时联系上了朱萍。虽然朱萍的英语非常蹩脚，但她不知怎么就说服了凯特琳飞过去探望。这将是凯特琳自母亲去世后第一次回家，也是我第一次见到父亲的两位中国妻子。
I pull up the familiar driveway in my Geo. Neither Kaitlin nor I say anything. We peer out the windows. The yard doesn't look too bad. There are new sprinklers and a kind of intricate irrigation system made of a network of ingeniously placed rain gutters. Soil has been turned, and thoughtfully. Cypruses have been trimmed. Enormous bundles of weeds flank the driveway, as though for some momentous occasion.
我开着我的Geo小车驶进熟悉的私家车道。凯特琳和我什么也没说。我们向窗外望去。院子看起来还不算太糟。装了新的喷灌系统，还有一套由巧妙放置的雨水槽组成的复杂灌溉系统。土壤被翻过，而且很用心地打理过。柏树被修剪了。一捆捆巨大的杂草堆在车道旁，仿佛为了迎接什么重大场合。
We ring the doorbell. Neither of us have had keys to the house in years. The door opens. A short, somewhat plump Chinese woman in round glasses and a perfect bowl haircut beams at us. She's wearing a bright yellow "I Hate Housework" apron that my mother was once given as a gag gift and I think never wore. "Kat-lin! Sand-wa!" she exclaims in what seems like authentic joy, embracing us. She is laughing and almost crying with emotion.
我们按响了门铃。我们俩已经多年没有家里的钥匙了。门开了。一位个子不高、稍微丰满的中国女性，戴着圆框眼镜，留着完美的波波头，向我们微笑。她穿着一件明黄色的“我讨厌家务”围裙，那是我母亲曾经收到的恶搞礼物，据我所知她从来没穿过。“凯特琳！桑德拉！”她用一种看起来极其真诚的喜悦感惊呼道，拥抱了我们。她笑着，几乎感动得哭了。
In spite of myself, giggles begin to well up from inside me, as if from a spring. I can't help it. I feel warm and euphoric. Authentic joy is contagious. Who cares who this woman is? No one has been this happy to see me in ages.
尽管我不愿意承认，笑声开始从我内心涌出，仿佛来自泉水。我忍不住了。我感到温暖和兴奋。真诚的喜悦是会传染的。谁在乎这个女人是谁？好久没人这么高兴见到我了。
"Welcome home," Zhu Ping says, with careful emphasis. She turns to Caitlin, a shadow falling over her face. "I am so glad you finally come home to see you daddy," she says in a low, sorrowful voice. She looks over her shoulder. "He old now." Then, as if exhausted by that effort, Zhu Ping collapses into giggles. I sneak a glance over at Kaitlin, whose expression seems to be straining somewhere between joy and nausea.
“欢迎回家，”朱萍说着，语气里带着谨慎的强调。她转向凯特琳，脸色闪过一丝阴影。“我很高兴你终于回家看你爸爸，”她声音低沉而悲伤地说道。她回头看了看。“他老了。”然后，仿佛被那个努力耗尽了力气，朱萍笑了起来。我偷偷瞥了一眼凯特琳，她的表情似乎在喜悦和反感之间挣扎。
I jump nervously in. "It's so nice to finally meet you. How do you like Los Angeles? I've heard so much about your cooking."
我紧张地插嘴。“很高兴终于见到你。你觉得洛杉矶怎么样？我听说了好多关于你厨艺的事情。”
My father goes off to put some music on his new CD player. "That bad Liu made me buy it," he exclaims. "But it is nice."
父亲走过去在他的新CD播放机上放些音乐。“那个坏女人刘让我买的，”他大声说，“但它确实不错。”
Zhu Ping bustles into the kitchen. "Dinner ready in five minute," she declares.
朱萍匆忙走进厨房。“晚餐五分钟就好，”她宣布。
Kaitlin waits a beat, then pulls me aside into the bathroom and slams the door. "This is so weird," she hisses. We have not stood together in this bathroom for some 15 years. It seems somehow different. I notice that the wallpaper is faded, the towels are new. But no, it's something else. On one wall is my mother's framed reproduction of the brown da Vinci etching called Praying Hands which she had always kept in her sewing room. Right next to it, in shocking juxtaposition, is a green, red, and yellow Bank of Canton calendar, featuring a zaftig Asian female in a bikini.
凯特琳等了一拍，然后把我拉进浴室，砰地关上门。“这太诡异了，”她嘶声说道。我们已经有15年没有一起站在这个浴室里了。这里看起来有些不同。我注意到墙纸褪色了，毛巾是新的。但不是，还有别的原因。墙上挂着我母亲珍藏的那幅棕色达芬奇蚀刻画《祈祷的手》(Praying Hands)，她一直把它放在缝纫室。而在它旁边，形成了一种令人震惊的对比，是一张绿色、红色和黄色的广东银行日历，上面画着一位穿着比基尼的身材丰满的亚洲女性。
"I can't go through with this," Kaitlin continues in stage whisper. "It's too weird. There are so many memories here. And not good ones." And like debris from a hurricane, the words tumble out. "I go by the kitchen and all I can see is me standing before the oven clock at age five with tears in my eyes. He is yelling, 'What time is it? The little hand is most of the way to 4 and the big hand is on the 8. It was 3:18 22 minutes ago, so what time is it now? What's 18 plus 22? Come on. You can do it in your head. Come on. Come on.' I go buy the dining room and I see him hurling my Nancy Drew books across the floor. They slam against the wall and I huddle against Mom. Screaming. 'Why do you waste your time on this when your algebra homework isn't finished? You good for nothing! You're nothing! Nothing! You'll never amount to anything!' I go by the bedroom--"
“我没法继续下去了，”凯特琳压低声音继续说。“这太诡异了。这里有太多的回忆。而且都不是什么好回忆。”就像飓风后的残骸，话语倾泻而出。“我经过厨房，脑子里只浮现出五岁时的我站在烤箱时钟前，眼里含着泪水。他在咆哮，‘几点了？短针快到4了，长针在8上。22分钟前是3点18分，那么现在几点？18加22是多少？快点。你在脑子里算一下。快点。快点。’我经过餐厅，看到他把我的南茜·朱尔(Nancy Drew)系列丛书扔得满地都是。它们撞击着墙壁，我蜷缩在妈妈身边。尖叫声。‘当你代数作业没做完时，你怎么浪费时间在这些东西上？你这没用的东西！你什么都不是！什么都不是！你这辈子也成不了气候！’我经过卧室……”
"Please." I have this sickening feeling like I'm going to cry, that I'm just going to lose it. I want to just sit down in the middle of the floor and roll myself into a ball. But I can't. Kaitlin's rage is like something uncontainable, a dreadful, natural force, and I am the gate keeper. I feel if I open the door, it will rush out and destroy the house and everything in it. "Please," is what I end up whispering. "Please, let's just eat. We'll be done in an hour. Then we can go home, I promise. You won't have to do this again for another 10 years. Or maybe ever."
“求你了。”我有一种令人作呕的感觉，仿佛要哭出来，仿佛要崩溃了。我只想坐在地板中间，把自己蜷成一团。但我不能。凯特琳的愤怒像是一种不可遏制的东西，一种可怕的自然力量，而我是守门人。我觉得如果我打开门，它会涌出来并摧毁房子和里面的一切。“求你了，”我最终低声说。“求你了，我们吃顿饭就好。一小时就能结束。然后我们就能回家，我保证。你以后十年都不用再做这种事了。或者永远不用。”
At dinner, endless plates of food twirl their way out of the kitchen, Zhu Ping practically dancing underneath. Spinach, teriyaki-ish chicken, shrimp, some kind of egg thing with peas, dumplings packed with little pillows of pork. And amazingly, there is no want of conversational material. Photos from Shanghai are being pulled out of envelopes and passed around of her family, his family.
晚餐时，无穷无尽的盘子从厨房里端出来，朱萍几乎是在下面跳着舞。菠菜、照烧风格的鸡肉、虾仁、某种带豌豆的蛋类料理，还有包着猪肉馅的小饺子。而且令人惊讶的是，聊天素材一点也不缺。她家、他家上海亲戚的照片从信封里拿出来传阅。
I do recognize three or four Chinese relatives, a cousin, an aunt, a grand uncle. Their names are impossible for me to remember. We had met them in China during our last trip as a family. I was 15. It was right before our mother started to get sick. Shanghai is a distant, confused memory for me of ringing bicycle bells and laundry lines hanging from buildings.
我确实认出了三四个中国亲戚，一个表亲，一个姑妈，一个伯祖父。他们的名字我根本记不住。我们最后一次以家庭身份去中国时见过他们。我15岁。那是母亲开始生病之前。上海对我来说是一个遥远而模糊的记忆，有着自行车铃声和悬挂在建筑间的晾衣绳。
What I do remember is how curious my father's family had seemed about Kaitlin and me, his odd American experiment, ooh-ing over our height and touching our auburn hair. There were many smiles but no intelligible conversation, at least to our ears. We probably won't see any of these people again before we die.
我唯一记得的是父亲的家人对凯特琳和我表现出的好奇，像对待他那项奇怪的美国实验品，对我们的身高啧啧称奇，抚摸我们红褐色的头发。有很多微笑，但没有清晰的对话，至少在我们听来是这样。我们可能这辈子再也见不到这些人了。
But Zhu Ping will have none of it. Hearty Manchurian builder that she is, she is determined to use the crude two by fours of her broken English to forge a rickety rope bridge between us. "You, Sand-wa, you. You play the piano, no? Mozart, he very nice. You will show me. And you, Kat-lin, you. You are a teacher, no? That is good, Kat-lin, good. Kat-lin, you are very, very good."
但朱萍才不管那一套。作为一名坚强的满洲女性，她决心用她蹩脚的英语作为粗糙的木板，在我们之间架起一座摇摇晃晃的绳桥。“你，桑德拉，你。你会弹钢琴，对吧？莫扎特，他非常好。你会表演给我看。还有你，凯特琳，你。你是老师，对吧？那很好，凯特琳，很好。凯特琳，你非常、非常好。”
My father puts his spoon down. He is chewing slowly, a frown growing. "This meat," he shakes his head, "is very, very greasy." He turns to Zhu Ping and the lines of both sides of his mouth deepen. His eyes cloud. He says something to her in Chinese with a certain sharp cadence that makes my spine stiffen. Zhu Ping's face goes blank for a moment. Her eyes grow big. My stomach turns to ice.
父亲放下勺子。他咀嚼得很慢，眉头紧锁。“这肉，”他摇摇头，“太油腻了。”他转向朱萍，嘴角两边的纹路加深了。他的眼神变得阴郁。他用一种尖锐的语调对她说了句中文，让我的脊背发凉。朱萍的表情空白了一瞬间。她的眼睛睁大了。我的胃结成了冰。
How will she respond? By throwing her napkin down? Bursting into tears? Running from the room? Will she knock the table over, plates sliding after each other, sauces spilling, crockery breaking? Will we hear the car engine turn over as she drives off into the night, leaving us here frightened and panicked?
她会怎么回应？摔掉餐巾？放声大哭？跑出房间？她会掀翻桌子，盘子滑落，酱汁泼洒，餐具破碎吗？我们会听到汽车引擎发动的声音，她开着车冲进夜色，留下惊慌失措的我们吗？
It is none of these things. Zhu Ping's head tilts back. Her eyes crinkle. And laughter pours out of her, peal after peal after peal. It is a big laugh, an enormous laugh, the laugh of a woman who has birthed calves and hoed crops and seen harsh winters decimate countrysides. Pointing to our father, Zhu Ping turns to us with large, glittering eyes and says, words which sound incredible to our ears. "You Papa, he so funny."
这些都没发生。朱萍的头向后倾。她的眼睛眯了起来。笑声从她口中迸发出来，一阵接一阵。那是一种爽朗的笑声，巨大的笑声，一个生过牛犊、锄过庄稼、见过寒冬摧毁村庄的女人的笑声。指着我们的父亲，朱萍转过身，用闪烁的大眼睛看着我们，说出了在我们听来不可思议的话。“你们的爸爸，他真逗。”
My jaw drops. No one has ever laughed out loud at this table ever. We laughed behind closed doors, in our bedrooms, in the bathroom, never before my father. We laughed sometimes with my mother on those glorious days when he would be off on a trip.
我惊得下巴都要掉了。在这张餐桌上，从来没人笑出过声。我们只在关起门来，在卧室里，在浴室里笑，从来没在父亲面前笑过。在母亲还在的日子里，当他出远门时，我们会偶尔笑出声来。
But Kaitlin is not laughing. She is trembling. Her face is turning red. "Why were you always so angry?" she cries out in a strangled voice. It's a question she's waited 30 years to ask. "Why were you so angry?"
但凯特琳没笑。她在颤抖。她的脸涨红了。“为什么你以前总是那么生气？”她嘶哑着嗓子喊道。这是她等待了30年才问出的问题。“为什么你总是那么生气？”
There is a shocked silence. My father looks weary and embarrassed. He smiles wanly and shrugs his thin shoulders. "No, really," Kaitlin insists, "all those years with Mama. Why?"
一片震惊的寂静。父亲看起来既疲惫又尴尬。他勉强笑了笑，耸了耸瘦削的肩膀。“不，说真的，”凯特琳坚持道，“那些和妈妈在一起的岁月。为什么？”
"I don't know," my father murmurs. "People get angry." And I know in that moment that he doesn't have an answer. He literally doesn't. It's as if rage was this chemical that reacted on him for 20 years. Who knows why, but like some kind of spirit, it has left him now. The rage is spent. He is old now. He is old.
“我不知道，”父亲喃喃道，“人总会生气的。”在那个瞬间，我知道他没有答案。他真的没有。就好像愤怒是一种化学物质，过去20年一直在他身上起反应。谁知道为什么，但就像某种幽灵，它现在离开了他。愤怒已经耗尽了。他现在老了。他老了。
Dusk is fallen and long shadows fall across the worn parquet floor of the dining room. After a moment of silence, my father asks Zhu Ping to sing a song. The house frau from Guangzhou opens her mouth and with an odd dignity, sings simply and slowly.
暮色降临，长长的阴影投射在餐厅磨损的拼花地板上。片刻的沉默后，父亲让朱萍唱首歌。这位来自广州的家庭主妇张开嘴，带着一种奇特的尊严，简单而缓慢地唱了起来。
My father translates. "From the four corners of the Earth, my lover comes to me playing the lute. Like the wind over the water." He recites the words without embarrassment, almost without emotion. And why shouldn't he? The song has nothing to do with him personally. It is from some old Chinese fable. It has to do with missing someone, something, someplace, that perhaps one can't even define anymore.
父亲翻译道：“从地球的四个角落，我的爱人向我走来，弹奏着琵琶。如同水面之上的清风。”他毫无尴尬地背诵着这些歌词，几乎不带任何感情。他为什么要有感情呢？这首歌与他个人无关。它出自某个古老的中国寓言。它讲述的是对某人、某事、某个地方的思念，或许人们甚至无法再明确定义那究竟是什么了。
As Zhu Ping sings, everyone longs for home. But what home? Zhu Ping, for her bitter winters? My father, for the Shanghai he left 40 years ago? And what about Kaitlin and I? We are even sitting in our own childhood home, and we long for it.
当朱萍唱起歌时，每个人都在渴望着家。但那是怎样的家呢？是朱萍那苦寒的故乡吗？是我父亲那他四十年前离开的上海吗？那我和凯特琳呢？我们甚至就坐在自己童年的家里，却依然在怀念它。
Papa, why don't you just take us out with a song?
爸爸，你为什么不干脆用一首歌带我们离开呢？
This song, usually, I sing with my wife. Since today, Sandra didn't invite my wife, I have to let her stay in the kitchen at home. This song describes a young woman longing for her lover. It sounds like this. [SINGING IN CHINESE]
这首歌，通常我是和我太太一起唱的。既然今天桑德拉没请我太太，我只好让她待在家里厨房里了。这首歌描述的是一位年轻女子思念她的爱人。听起来是这样的。[演唱中文歌曲]
Our program was produced today by Peter Clowney and by myself, with Alix Spiegel, Nancy Updike and Dolores Wilber. Contributing editors, Paul Tough, Jack Hitt and Margy Rochlin.
今天的节目由彼得·克劳尼和我制作，艾利克斯·斯皮格尔、南希·厄普代克和多洛雷斯·威尔伯参与制作。特约编辑为保罗·托夫、杰克·希特和玛吉·罗克林。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
"My Father's Chinese Wives," was first published in Quarterly West. Sandra's own book is called Depth Takes a Holiday -- that's "depth"-- Essays from Lesser Los Angeles. If you would like to buy a copy of this program, it's only $10. Call us, WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380, 312-832-3380. Or you can write us at WBEZ, 848 East Grand Avenue, Chicago, Illinois 60611. Or you can email us. Our email address [email protected] , [email protected] .
《我父亲的中国妻子们》首次发表于《西方季刊》。桑德拉本人的书名为《深度的假期》（Depth Takes a Holiday）——是“深度”这个词——副标题为“来自小洛杉矶的散文”。如果您想购买本期节目的拷贝，仅需10美元。请致电芝加哥WBEZ电台，电话312-832-3380，312-832-3380。或者您可以写信给我们，地址是WBEZ, 848 East Grand Avenue, Chicago, Illinois 60611。您也可以给我们发电子邮件，我们的邮箱地址是 [email protected] , [email protected] 。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia. I'm Ira Glass.
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Papa, I'm going to tell this story now the way I tell it. So I hope you're not embarrassed, OK?
爸爸，现在我要用我自己的方式来讲述这个故事了。所以我希望你不要感到尴尬，好吗？
OK. What choice do I have?
好吧。我还有别的选择吗？
Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
下周我们将带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。